[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire nous allons passer toute
cette émission avec audio une hymne les
professeurs agrégés de l'histoire et
vient de publier aux éditions du chêne
il vivait en couleurs un gros livre de
photos datant du temps du noir et blanc
entre 1838 et 1945 qui ont été
colorisées ou plutôt on leur a rendu
leur couleur ce qui en fait un livre
d'histoire tout à fait surprenant mais
commençons d'abord par ce qui
caractérise notre époque comme c'est la
tradition dans cette émission
voici l'image que vous avez choisie elle
a fait le tour du monde
alors pourquoi celle-ci et bien
justement parce qu'elle a fait le tour
du monde
je trouvais ça intéressant dans la
mesure où aujourd'hui je vous présente
des photos d'histoire à l'époque où à la
photographie était complètement
exceptionnel je vous présente même pas
les toutes premières photos là ce qui
est impressionnant je trouve dans le
phénomène de jackass johnny angeli que
tout le monde connaît maintenant c'est
qu'en une semaine son visage a fait le
tour de la planète et je trouvais ça
intéressant est symptomatique notre
société actuelle où il ya une sur
représentation de l'image où l'image et
partager instantanément et
reproductibles ce qui n'était pas le cas
on ne fera peut-être tout à l'heure avec
les daguerréotypes et que et que ça
apporte aussi des travers pour notre
société qui est beaucoup dans l'émotion
beaucoup dans l'instantané beaucoup dans
la photo sans explications parfois sans
contexte et qui peuvent amener à une
manipulation des foules comme je trouve
que ça peut ça peut amener à fragiliser
nos démocraties occidentales et qu'on
l'a bien vu mercredi dernier avec 7 à
chaud du capital et puis il faut dire
que la photo s'est fortement banalise et
surtout depuis ce début de xxième siècle
tout le monde ayant un appareil photo
dans sa poche mais tout à coup les
photos qui qui deviennent mémorable ce
sont celles qui justement quelque chose
d'exceptionnel et c'est le cas de celle
ci a bien entendu tout à fait ça c'est
ce que c'est la partie qui en commun
avec mon livre c'est que si cette photo
a fait le tour du monde c'est aussi
parce que
elle est exceptionnel parce que elle
elle marque les esprits et c'est ce que
j'ai essayé de faire avec le livre que
je vais vous présenter aujourd'hui c'est
à dire montrer seulement des photos qui
marque vraiment l'histoire est qui et
qui interpellent et qui ont un petit
effet ou et bien commençons
[Musique]
audio et mines pourquoi ce livre ce
livre que je tient dans la main qui est
très gros seins qui est très épais il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de photos vous voulez
vous ne les verrez pas toutes toutes
celles que vous allez voir sont
évidemment à l'intérieur mais pourquoi
avez vous fait ce livre on sait bien que
nos ancêtres ne vivait pas en noir et
blanc
qu'est ce que vous avez voulu montrer en
leur rendant leur couleur ces lycéens
c'est un carrefour de trois passions
déjà une passion tout simplement pour
l'histoire évidemment mais aussi pour la
photographie historique même une photo
en noir et blanc moi je comme beaucoup
de français on est très attiré par
l'image qui nous permet de comprendre et
c'est vraiment des photos qui en général
sont très instructives en fait quand on
regarde le moindre détail on peut en
apprendre beaucoup et en comprendre
beaucoup sur l'esprit même d'un siècle
et avec les techniques actuelles de
colorisation ça c'est la troisième bonne
raison on avait pu voir ces dernières
années des documentaires historiques
tout à fait marquant comme apocalypse un
peu plus proche de nous l'année dernière
une si belle époque sondés des
reportages qui nous montre des vidéos
colorisées est vraiment j'ai été marqué
à chaque fois j'ai eu un véritable coup
de foudre comme beaucoup encore une fois
beaucoup de français pour ce
rapprochement qui se fait instantanément
on a le sentiment que ce sont d'autres
nous mêmes alors que parfois le filtre
du noir et blanc nous éloigne comme si
c'était une autre humanité comme si
c'était une époque où les gens n'étaient
pas tout à fait semblables à nous alors
en grand dans les couleurs
autant je trouvais que c'était rendre la
réalité on va en avoir la preuve tout de
suite avec une des premières photos du
livre cet enfant de onze ans qui
travaillent
enfin qui travaillait dans une mine aux
états unis en 1908 en noir et blanc il
aurait eu l'air d'un fantôme
quelqu'un de dindane aude qui nous est
totalement étranger là ils ressemblent
aux enfants d'aujourd'hui
c'est très frappant un exactement
exactement ça reste pour être notre fils
notre neveu à notre cousin et là on
réalise tout à coup que c'est un enfant
qui travaille alors qu'avec le prisme du
noir et blanc on aurait pu dire c'est
une autre époque où d'autres moeurs etc
là on vraiment il son humanité nous nous
nous nous sautent au visage
et puis ses yeux nous parle sa posture
un peu bravache qui en fait d'ailleurs
est peut-être due à une maladie il avait
les jambes un peu raide mais sa posture
un peu bravache nous nous semble
d'autant plus humaine et irréel voilà
c'est pas un fantôme il est bien vivant
comme son vivant les enfants suivant qui
eux travaillaient dans une mine en
sicile et on découvre qu'en sicile
à cette époque là il y avait des
esclaves en étant 1899 et vous raconter
que ces enfants sont des esclaves tout à
fait et il ya vraiment même si le mot
esclave n'est pas employé pour pour le
statut qu'ils occupaient il est tout à
fait similaire à l' esclavage et
d'ailleurs j'ai voulu faire publier un
témoignage d'un ancien esclave qui
racontent ce que ce qu'il voit en sicile
et le plus proche qu'il espère voir de
toute sa vie de l'enfer autrement dit
ils espèrent que jamais il ne verra pire
que la condition de ces enfants qui m'a
terriblement émue à vrai dire mais
vraiment c'était deux enfants sans
famille dont don en fait soit la famille
étaient trop pauvres soit pardon qui
sortait d'un orphelinat qui qui étaient
occupées employé par une entreprise de
d'exploitation de mine de soufre et
souffre sa porte bien son nom puisqu'il
souffrait toute la journée dans le sens
où il portait des sacs beaucoup trop
lourd pour pour leur âge et il avait
très régulièrement des déficits
intellectuels mais aussi bien sûr des
déficits physique notamment en perdant
la vue beaucoup disent il faut y amener
aveugle il faut y être
il vivait dans la mine il dormait dans
la mine
c'était absolument épouvantable esclaves
américains enfin l'ancien esclave que
vous citez cboe coeur ti washington qui
a joué un rôle important évidemment à
cette époque là et qui était venu en
sicile effectivement pour l'épauler
visiter les petits vendeurs de journaux
de richmond en virginie en étant en 1911
on en a vu beaucoup des petits belges en
de vendeur de journaux comme ça dans les
films muets dans le documentaire on les
voit y sont tout petits ils ont migré
ils ont une plainte journaux mais là
tout à coup ils sont vraiment là quoi
ils sont vraiment là encore une fois il
ressemble à nos enfants
ouais effectivement vous avez raison de
le dire c'est vraiment un
un thème favori enfin en tout cas et qui
revient souvent dans soit la littérature
américaine soit soit les films
donc on les connaît mais à les voir si
petit haut comme trois pommes comme on
dit et puis si proche de nous finalement
pas ce que c'était c'est la couleur qui
qui permet de se rappeler à quel point
ça pourrait être ça pourrait aux enfants
là là je trouvais intéressant de voir
aussi les pieds nus qui éclate aux yeux
quand grâce à la couleur ce qu'on aurait
peut-être pas vu c'était du gris ce qui
permet de comprendre que la condition de
ces enfants de 5-6 ans était était déjà
de gagner leur vie assez durement à l
époque où nous nos enfants sont en
grande maternelle alors il ya aussi des
enfants qui ne travaillait pas il y en
avait même qui s'amusait on avait le
droit
on a souvent on pense souvent là
l'enfance de cette époque comme
extrêmement difficile à vivre
engoncés dans des règles là on quand on
voit ces petites filtre sur la plage de
brighton en angleterre on voit qu'elle
s'amusait exactement comme les enfants
d'aujourd'hui s'amuse et quand elles
font comme ça devant loeb le photographe
semblant de fumée on voit bien qu'il ya
pas de tabou puis le mimétisme et des
adultes est assez intéressant la
petite-fille de droite imite visiblement
son père ou peut-être essaye de de se
poser comme une jeune dame de l'époque
mais c'était tout l'objet de mon
chapitre d'essayer de montrer qu'il y
avait des enfants qui travaillait et
puis il
des enfants qui jouaient comme
aujourd'hui heureusement dans nos
sociétés la plupart des enfants jouent
mais comme à travers la planète d'autres
enfants continuent de travailler
et oui c'est ses petites filles j'ai
beaucoup hésité sur le titre parce que
je trouve qu'il ya comme une certaine je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
presque une sexualisation qui se dégage
de la petite fille en train de mimer
l'acte de fumer et donc c'était presque
troublant et et j'ai voulu par le titre
préserver la l'innocence de l'enfance
mais mais comme vous dites il ya quand
même 7 cette question qui vient à
l'esprit de la question du tabou et
alors vous êtes amusé à faire un quiz
on va le voir avec des des photos de
bébé devenu célèbre par la suite on va
on va tous les voir alors c'est assez
amusant de de se dire que tout en haut à
gauche il ya charles de gaulle
à côté de lui c'est alfred hitchcock le
maître du suspense c'est alfred
hitchcock en dessous de charles de
gaulle tout à gauche c'est emile zola si
je me trompe pas à côté des milles c'est
là c'est grace kelly
ils sont c'est vrai que tous ces bébés
bien rose et bien alors si on l'autre
page on a à la fois
elisabeth deux très très jolie ressemble
presque à l'actrice qui l'interprète de
crohn quand elle est jeune elle était
vraiment mignonne à côté elle ressemble
surtout à la petite charlotte cht revin
oui peut-être effectivement à côté
d'elle celui avec la coiffe à la jeanne
d'arc et les yeux ébahis et vous l'avez
titre et 50 millions de morts c'est
adolf hitler
il a été à bébé comme les autres et puis
en bas à gauche ici même c c malines
monroe est là presque aussi beau que
marilyn monroe c'est jean paul sartre
comme quoi parfois il faudrait pas que
ça grandit
parce que jean paul sartre là il est
rapidement c'est incroyable avec avec
son cheveu très malade ou une fois dans
sa vie où il vivait très romantique
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que
quand on voit quand on présente la photo
de sartre c'est ce que évidemment je me
suis amusé à faire avec ma famille et
mes amis de sartre ou de de gaulle un
tout le monde a cru que c'était des
petites filles oui bien sûr mais à
l'époque on sait bien que les petits
garçons on leur laissait les les cheveux
longs et paris via mon les habillant
petite fille et on trouvait pas sa
problématique ni criminel continuons
dans votre livre il ya beaucoup de
photos de sport on va en voir quelques
unes et notamment celles ci des
aristocrates allemand jouant au
badminton en double mixte dans leur
château un là on est en 1900 dont voilà
c'est des gens qui vont pour la plupart
mourir pendant la première guerre
mondiale en tout cas les hommes ceux qui
ont des uniformes et même les petits
garçons
là ils s'amusent et les femmes aussi ont
droit de faire du sport exactement elles
sont à égalité avec avec les hommes donc
c'est un double mixte
est ce que je trouvais amusant c'était à
la fois l'histoire même du badminton
parce que il a été inventé par des
aristocrates anglais qu'il s'ennuyait
dans la ville de badminton et qui en
planter des soins musée a planté des des
plumes dans un bouchon de champagne et
taper dedans et a trouvé que ce sport
était géniale et on dit tu n'es dicter
les règles très officiellement quatre
ans plus tard donc l'histoire du
badminton m'amuse
l'histoire de ce sport mais aussi de
voir cette photo avec notamment la dame
du fond avec son chapeau pendant qu'elle
joue je trouvais ça 6,6 aristocratique
et cielecran à la fois que j'avais envie
de mettre en valeur cette photo ouais
c'est un peu prussiens aussi un quand
même un côté très précieux dans cette
faute et m notamment les âmes sur le
côté son frère moi moi prochaine la
photo suivante c'est suzanne lenglen
on est en 1922 suzanne lenglen vous le
rappeler elle a gagné six fois
roland-garros six fois wimbledon
les années 20 c'est vraiment des années
une décennie au cours de laquelle les
français dominent complètement le tennis
côté hommes on allait les fameux
mousquetaires borotra lacoste qui
l'emportent absolument partout c'est
formidable quand on voit cette photo
alors aujourd'hui il ya encore des
françaises qui gagne des tournois du
grand chelem mais en revanche les hommes
n'en gagnent plus aucun ça fait 60 ans
70 ans les hommes ont gagné un tournoi
du grand chelem roland garros 183 par
yannick noah c'est le seul depuis 1946
on ne gagne plus rien en tennis et ça
n'a l'air d'étonner personnes alors
qu'on était si bon bah c'est un peu
dommage il nous faut des suzanne lenglen
de retour et puis surtout à des hommes
comme olivier des borotra de retour mais
je trouvais cette photo très amusante
parce qu'on voit les
les grandes robes et puis même le bas de
suzanne lenglen qui dépassent de sa robe
donc c'était ça que j'aimais bien dans
cette photo mais effectivement vous avez
raison ça nous interpelle sur
l'hégémonie française dans la décennie
de 1920 qui s'est malheureusement un peu
éclipsée mais bon on est on est en train
de rentrer dans la décennie 2020 donc
son temps plus tard ça veut dire un
retour peut-être oui allez savoir il ya
une faute au delà de jesse owens très
célèbre et ans pour une fois vous n'avez
pas imprimez la légende vous avez
rétabli la réalité en effet vous dites
dans le commentaire de cette photo
magnifique artistes athlètes de sierentz
mais dont on se souvient parce que
soi-disant pendant les jeux olympiques
de berlin en 1936 hitler aurait refusé
de saluer c'est totalement faux jesse
owens l'a raconté dans son
autobiographie mais on continue de
raconter n'importe quoi
en réalité il perd non seulement lui a
fait un salut mais ils n'avaient plus le
droit à ce moment là de lui serrer la
main parce qu'on avait dit qu'il serait
trop main mais ce que raconte jesse
owens qui est bien plus dramatique c'est
que s'il y en a qui a refusé de lui
serrer la main en revanche c'est
franklin roosevelt c'est le président
des états unis tout à fait qui a refusé
de le recevoir et qui lui a pas non plus
envoyé de télégrammes effectivement
c'est une bonne question pourquoi cette
anecdote continue à être père pétain a
perduré dans l'imaginaire collectif je
pense tout simplement que tout le monde
aimerait croire que hitler a été humilié
parce que on déteste tous hitler et donc
c'est enfin les gens croient facilement
ce qu'ils ont envie de croire mais à une
ère où la désinformation
on le disait en introduction un peut
être très dangereuse c'est important
effectivement de rétablir les faits et
ce qui est terrible dans son
autobiographie c'est que jesse owens
racontait qu'au fond les seuls moments
de sa vie où il avait pu vivre librement
c'était à berlin sous le nazisme pendant
les jeux olympiques
non pas qu'il avait la moindre sympathie
pour ce régime mais qu'il était bien
obligé de constater que la trêve
olympique et dans tout le monde était à
égalité à berlin même sous le nazisme
alors quand les états unis dès qu'il est
rentré il a été victime de la
ségrégation et et le président des états
unis qui voulaient se faire réélire
aux prochaines élections a refusé de le
recevoir parce qu'ils espéraient bien
avoir le vote des racistes du sud c'est
c'était ça la réalité voilà c'est pas la
légende et autres autres photos alors
qu'ils sont très frappante ce sont les
photos des expositions universelles
quelque chose qu'on ne connaît plus ou
quasiment plus aujourd'hui
voilà c'était un déluge de modernité de
splendeur les les les expositions
universelles celles ci c'est à londres
en 1853
quel est ce bâtiment qu'est ce qu'il a
dit il est fascinant ce bâtiment en 1853
on a l'impression d'être au milieu du
xxème siècle oui les plus simples ans il
est époustouflant et évidemment on est
triste à l'idée que il est il et flamber
finalement dans les années 30
au 20e siècle le crystal palace c'est
vraiment l'histoire aussi du triomphe
d'un peuple le peuple britannique
quand il a été érigé pour pour
l'exposition universelle de 1851 passé
c'est l'horreur en fait de de ce qu'on a
appelé par la suite l'économie monde
britanniques ou vraiment et on a une
hégémonie économique culturel et des de
la grande bretagne et ce crayon se voit
aussi au travers de leurs réalisations
pendant cette exposition universelle et
le crystal palace a ébloui évidemment
ses contemporains sait bien que même si
il a il a péri il ya plus de 90 ans il
reste encore dans nos mémoires et
vraiment cette photo comme vous dites
est d'une grande modernité
on va voir la paris en 1900 autre
exposition universelle
on va voir les bords de la seine il faut
bien imaginer que tout ça c'était
éphémères sont des constructions
éphémères sont les pavillons de
différents pays qui ont été érigées
juste pour le temps de l'exposition
universelle c'est destiné à être détruit
c'est absolument incroyable c'est ça que
je trouve très fascinant et je suis
heureuse que que l'on puisse le
ressentir grâce à cette photo parce que
vraiment je trouve ça époustouflant que
de telles merveilles a été fait pour six
mois à peine au premier plan
voix à gauche le pavillon belge qui
représente 5 est très fortement inspiré
de celui de de liège sur la place de
liège mais il ya vraiment une
une exceptionnelle un art exceptionnel
qui a été déployé pour quelque chose de
très éphémère et qui montre vraiment le
prodige est capable d'être réalisés à
l'époque alors c'était les matériaux qui
de toute manière n'était pas durable
c'était souvent du plâtre et du bois
donc ça pouvait s'effondrer très
facilement donc il faut pas regretter
que ces été détruits ça n'aurait pas pu
a perduré
mais c'est quand même prodigieuse qu'ils
ont réussi à réaliser
du moins en apparence et on imagine ce
qu'un parisien où un visiteur du monde
pouvait pouvait ressentir en prenant un
bateau mouche et en arpentant ce qu'on
appelait la rue des nations c'est à dire
la scène tout simplement bas on
voyageait pas donc on nous a menés à
domicile l'exotisme des pays voisins
on va voir maintenant paris en 1937
alors le pavillon du trocadéro tel qu'on
l'a changée à l'époque révolutionner il
est toujours là le mais on ne voit plus
heureusement ni le pavillon soviétique
ni le pavillon nazi qui se faisait face
l'un l'autre
1937 paris alors la statue au premier
plan elle et elle est parisienne mais on
voit derrière le à gauche le monument
soviétique et puis à droite avec l'aigle
au dessus
le pavillon nazi oui il ya toute une
histoire sur la concurrence entre la
hauteur respective de l'aigle et la
statue de des russes et on dit que
les allemands avaient surélevé leurs
bâtiments pour pouvoir doubler la statue
la statue soviétique quand ils ont vu
que elle risquait de dépasser leurs
propres règles alors j'ai pas réussi à
savoir cette anecdote était était vrai
ou pas mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
vraiment on voit les deux des deux
impérialisme qui se font face et les
deux totalitarismes
en l'occurrence qui s'affrontent au
travers de cette photo mais alors ce qui
est drôle c'est que cette photo enfin
tout cas des photos similaires
représentant c2pay vie on en connaît
plein normalement elles sont en noir et
blanc ce qui donne immédiatement à côté
sinistre on est en 1937 on a
l'impression que la guerre va éclater
d'un instant à l'autre
mais quand vous l'avez recolorisées on
retrouve j'imagine l'atmosphère qui
devait y avoir à paris à ce moment là
quand les gens venaient à l'exposition
universelle et finalement qui trouvaient
que tout ça était très joyeux très joli
et est plein de promesses pour l'avenir
oui c'est ça les lourds nuages
disparaissent du moment qu'on rend à sa
couleur au ciel bleu et on se on se
garde de la vision telle téléologique
qui fait que maintenant on sait comment
s'est terminé l'histoire et les
contemporains ne le savait pas quand il
arpentait cette exposition universelle
et il pouvait être plein d'espoir et je
trouvais que la statue parisienne au
premier plan qui incarne un peu la
blancheur de l'innocence parisienne
montrait bien peut être sept cette
hésitation ce regard un peu angélique
sur sur le monde il ya un phénomène du
début du siècle du début du xxème siècle
qu'on a oublié aujourd'hui et qu'on a
peu connu en france d'ailleurs ce sont
les suffragettes les chiffrages est
anglaise était extraordinaire en voilà
une en mai par la police en 1914
c'était d'une très grande violence le
combat des fruits de suffragettes on se
rend pas compte sont des femmes très
souvent issue de la grande bourgeoisie
ou de l'aristocratie elles luttent pour
avoir le droit de vote et d'ailleurs
elles vont l'obtenir en 1918 les femmes
anglaises auront le droit de voter
femmes britanniques les françaises
devront attendre une autre guerre
mondiale vingt ans plus tard donc mais
mais elles elles y parviennent peut-être
parce qu'elles sont violentes au fond
exactement c'est toute la question
les suffragettes effectivement on
accepte et déjà leur leur nom de
suffragettes qui était péjoratif
initialement et puis à la dame convoi
pancartes
elle a accepté l'idée de la violence
elle a même revendiqué
l'idée de 2 d'un combat légitime avec
des moyens vu comme illégitime par
exemple des incendies donc des moyens
qu'on qualifierait un peu de terroristes
et elle s'était fait une spécialité de
provoquer tellement
la police et le gouvernement là elle
venait déposer une pétition elle est
emmenée de force par un policier elle va
finir en prison
c'était une fait une spécialité
justement de séjour en prison qui à
chaque fois la rentrée rendait de plus
en plus célèbres d'autant qu'elle
réussissait en sortir avec des grèves de
la faim et c'est c'est par des moyens
non conventionnels qu'elle a atteint un
but qui aujourd'hui nous semble
évidemment conventionnelle c'est à dire
le droit de vote des femmes
il y en a une qui est morte dans ce jeu
de danse précipitant sur un champ de
courses devant les sabots du cheval du
roi d'angleterre à l'époque
et puis très connus marie richardson qui
elle est allée l'a serrée avec un
hachoir à viande
un célèbre tableau de vélasquez la vénus
au miroir ou à la national gallery
elle gît allait pas de main morte un et
vous avez peur de rien et et ça a payé
ouais c'est toute la question de deux
fautes il employer des moyens violents
pour se faire vraiment entendre oui
dernières photos avant la pause c'est la
crise de 29
elle et elle est magnifique comme photo
et le jaune de la voiture durant toute
sa beauté
voilà un homme qui vient de tout perdre
à la bourse au moment du crash de wall
street et qui vend sa très belle voiture
pour 100 dollars mais il les veut en
liquide
parce que explique-t-il il n'a plus rien
voilà une photo vraiment elle est peu
connu d'ailleurs celle ci on y en a
beaucoup plus connu sur la crise de 29
celle ci elle est peu connu mais la
couleur lui rend tout ça ça mais j'ai ce
qu aux hits et oui on voit le regard
désabusé de trenton qui d'ailleurs a été
célèbre par la suite mais qui est
tellement symptomatique de de la
désillusion qui s'est emparée de
beaucoup d'américains plus
spécifiquement des new yorkais
de wall street du quartier de retraite à
cette époque là que j'aime beaucoup et
effectivement comme je le précise
légende il vend sa voiture 100 dollars
c'est-à-dire concrètement 6% du prix
qu'ils l'avaient qu'il avait dépensé
l'année juste avant en pleine croissance
des années des années folles pour pour
acheter cette voiture est effectivement
j'aime beaucoup cette color 7
colorisation ce travail a été très bien
fait je trouve c'est la vraie couleur
originale et original et j'aime beaucoup
et c'est un peu cette photo on fait une
pause on se retrouve juste après avec
beaucoup d'autres photos en couleurs
[Musique]
ils vivent est en couleur 1838 1945
c'est le titre de ce livre pour remonter
le temps en couleur il est signé aux 2
go et mines et vient de paraître aux
éditions du chêne on continue de le
feuilleter avec vous au 2 et l'on
revient sur encore des femmes
[Rires]
des femmes à bord d'une voiture et pas
n'importe quelle voiture c'est la jamais
contente c'est une voiture électrique
on croit qu'on est tout inventé en ce
21ème siècle
pas du tout on se contente d'innover de
refaire en un petit peu mieux ce qu'on
avait fait avant
la preuve la voiture électrique existait
déjà en 1920 et même bien avant la
plupart des premières voitures étaient
tout électrique
exactement alors celle là c'est pas la
jamais contente qui a battu un record de
vitesse mais c'était une une des
nombreuses un des nombreux exemplaires
de voiture électrique qui a été
popularisé mais qui aux yeux des hommes
allait à une vitesse un peu trop lente
effectivement elle était souvent limité
à 35 kilomètres heure mais ce qui nous
frappe aujourd'hui c'est de voir que
certes 35 km heure c'est sans doute
insuffisant aux yeux mais que c'était
c'était non seulement très populaire
mais tellement banal que c'était avec
mépris réservé aux femmes alors que
aujourd'hui on est tout ébaubi de
s'apercevoir qu'on peut faire rouler des
voitures électriques et ça nous semble
magique éclat nouveau alors que ce n'est
pas du tout nouveau la photo suivante
date de 1935 sont deux annonces il ya
d'abord la trottinette électrique prix
là où ça aussi on croit que c'est
nouveau
pas du tout un les postiers et même la
police en étaient équipées aux états
unis
dans les années c'est quoi ça c'est les
années 10 ou les années 20 oui c'est ça
à 1915
cette photo est génial je trouve parce
qu'elle est d'une modernité assez
frappante on croirait que c'est la ruée
actuelle de paris envahi par toutes les
trottinettes alors celle là précisément
n'est pas électrique même si le brevet
avait été déposée deux ans peu plus tôt
en 1913 celle-là et thermique avec les
petits moteurs qu'on voit sur le côté
mais les deux modèles en plus pliable
tout comme tout comme aujourd'hui
existait bien il ya plus de 100 ans et
alors moi ce qui me ce qui me fascine
aussi c'est la modernité des trains des
années 30 on va on va en voir un tout de
suite là alors c'est un train américain
1 mais sait il est absolument c'est de
la science fiction 1
aujourd'hui on pourrait l'imaginer dans
un film de rétro futuriste en et en
quelle année on né en 1936 et on se
croirait dans une bd de enki bilal
enfin c'est vraiment un effectivement
c'est rétro futuriste comme vous dites
c'est magnifique et ça a eu un grand
succès justement ce train a eu un grand
succès du fait même de son graphisme
assez époustouflant photo suivante alors
elle beaucoup plus anciennes là on a
l'impression de revenir en arrière et
pourtant on est au milieu du 19e siècle
sont des soldats écossais les mêmes vont
se battre à la bataille de sébastopol
l'année suivante en 1855 et là on a
vraiment l'impression qu'on n'a pas du
tout progressé depuis
depuis napoléon coin c'est à dire que
les soldats sont toujours bariolés
déguisé on sent qu'il se sent qu'ils
vont pas vont pas tarder à les charger
la baïonnette au son du tambour tous en
rang alors c'est drôle parce que j'ai
une interprétation un peu différente sur
cette photo moi ce qui me frappe c'est
au contraire la modernité des visages je
trouve vraiment qu'on croirait des
hipsters dans la rue les trois visages
avec les sourcils un peu français on
dirait des hommes sur les magazines
sur la couverture de gicquiaud est alors
en revanche vous avez raison la rue ni
forme les dates très profondément et là
ça se rapproche bien de l'armée
napoléonienne avec tout le décorum avant
d'être utile on voulait être
on voulait être beau ce qui a cessé on
sait en 1914 quand on s'est aperçu que
si on habille et nous nos soldats avec
des pantalons très joli mais un rouge ça
leur permettait de se faire tirer comme
des lapins donc on a cessé de vouloir
être beau et on a voulu être efficace
cela dit si vous voulez regarder comme
des comme des mannequins dans une chic
où effectivement à ce moment là lors
leurs portes à londres deviennent très
moderne et on les porte devant les
portes c'est pantalon là les médailles
qui sont plus à la mode mais peut-être
que ça va revenir et la photo suivante
c'est là c'est pendant la guerre
d'espagne sont des femmes républicaines
au moment du siège de l'alcazar et alors
je parle de la photo de droite bien
entendu et alors là je vous nous
apprenez enfin vous me l'avez appris à
moi en tout cas que dès l'instant où on
voit des femmes tiré au fusil pour la
guerre d'espagne c'est forcément des
républicaine tout à fait loyal à faire
un clivage très nette entre les deux
camps dans le camp répond républicain la
vision est évidemment de la femme était
mais c'est connu beaucoup moins
rétrograde du côté du côté franquiste
on assume est de considérer la femme
comme réservé à l'espace du foyer et
notamment à élever les enfants et à
faire la cuisine donc jamais on aurait
autorisé une femme à prendre un choisi
du côté franquiste il ne pouvait être
que ça et fermière donc tout à fait
pareil tout à fait là on va voir des des
images des célèbres inondations de 1910
à paris
elles ont beaucoup marqué des souvenirs
de nos aïeux un ces inondations et pour
cause là on les voit mieux que jamais on
a vraiment l'impression d'être à venise
ça a duré dites-vous 45 jours c'est
incroyable pendant 45 jours on avait de
l'eau jusque là oui ça vraiment
totalement arrêté la vie le commerce
tout a été réorganisé en fonction de
cette de cette crue exceptionnelle et
c'est pourquoi elle a autant marqué
l'histoire
en fait ce qui est curieux est amusant
c'est que les hommes ont dû s'adapter à
la longueur de cette crue et on connaît
les
les sénateurs ou des députés qui allait
en barque à l'assemblée nationale donc
c'est c'est assez frappant pour nous de
penser que les hommes avaient dû
s'adapter à cette situation cela dit
comme je le rappelle dans le dans le
commentaire
c'était pas que amusant là on voit
quatre personnes qui passent sur une
petite un petit pont de bois de fortune
elles ont l'air amusé elles font des
vagues sourire et elles sont
probablement en train de d'espérer ne
pas tomber
mais bon il ya eu de nombreux morts et
puis nous pas seulement d'ailleurs des
morts humains mais aussi énormément
d'animaux qui ont été noyés dans les
élevages
parce qu' il pouvait pas nager donc il
faut savoir qu'à l'époque était
uniquement quelque chose d'amusant
à l'époque la population qui savaient
nager était quand même très très minimes
1 on apprenait pas nager comme on
apprend à nager aujourd'hui oui ça c'est
sûr et certain ça va peut-être nous
amener vers des photos de vacances plus
tard j'ai montré mes d'abord nerfs
j'avais pensé aux deux orphelins du
titanic
parce qu'eux aussi ont failli se noyer
ils ont été très célèbre à l'époque
qu'un ces deux orphelins parce qu'ils
sont arrivés aux états unis
une fois que les îles et les rescapés
ont été emmenés et c'est les seuls qu'on
a pas réussi à identifier au départ oui
parce que c'était les salles qui avaient
perdu leur père et leur mère
donc on a appelé en vain l'un ou l'autre
on n'a pas compris leur prénom parce
qu'en fait ils étaient français donc on
leur posait la question en anglais ben
on était on a indiqué vous voyez
l'inscription en haut de la photo
louis et lola point d'interrogation
savais même pas c'est là c'est le petit
garçon était une fille ou un garçon
et on s'est aperçu bien plus tard que
l'histoire est très tragique derrière il
s'agit d'un père qui a voulu enlever ses
deux fils à la garde de sa femme sa
femme qui souhaitait divorcer et qui
était d'ailleurs déjà en couple avec un
autre homme
donc il a profité du week end de pâques
pour enlever les deux garçons passé de
manière anonyme du côté de la grande
bretagne avec un faux passeport et puis
ensuite si ces faits il s'est embarqué
sur le titanic en prenant le nom de
l'obs de nîmes d'un de ses amis
donc c'était impossible en fait de de
retracer l'identité réelle de ces
enfants est en fait la photo ayant fait
le tour du monde
l enquête ayant été du monde et déjanté
on a retrouvé la mère qui a recueilli
ses deux fils est bien plus tard michel
lainé
a confié que au moment où son père le
mettez dans son dans le canot de
sauvetage parce que son père a attendu
jusqu'à la dernière minute pour les
mettre il espérait pouvoir partir avec
ses fils mais c'était interdit aux
adultes devons monter sur les canaux des
enfants et donc à la dernière seconde et
s'est décidé à se séparer de ses deux
enfants il a lié à son fils tu diras à
ta mère que je l'aimé beaucoup et que je
souhaitais l'a fait revenir en amérique
donc l'histoire est assez assez
touchante et il s'appelait les les
frères navratil on en a beaucoup en
mesure de lui parler après autres autres
photos celle de marc trichard qu'on va
voir ici alors marthe richard a attaché
son nom à la loi qui interdit les les
maisons closes en france en 1946 mais
avant elle avait eu beaucoup d'aventurés
elle avait commencé tragiquement sa vie
puisqu'elle s'était prostituées à l'âge
de 16 ans dans des conditions
épouvantables c'est ce qui lui fera
fermer les maisons closes 20 ans ou 30
ans plus tard
oui trente ans plus tard puisque elle a
commencé pendant quarante ans plus tard
elle s'est prostituée dans les années
elle avait 16 ans en 1906 1907
cette photo là étaient présents en 1915
si je me souviens bien
au moment où elle est sortie tout
s'applique elle a épousé un de ses
clients qui étaient très riches qui l'a
initié à l'aviation elle est devenue une
des premières avaient aviatrice
française et c'est à ce moment là qu'on
la voit hélas exactement elle nous
paraît une femme d'aujourd'hui un
complètement et elle me fait elle me
fait penser à une actrice actuelle
d'ailleurs une actrice norvégienne
mais bref mais en tout cas elle est l'un
des cinq vraiment extraordinaire elle
est passée de la très grande pauvreté et
puis surtout pas simplement de la
pauvreté économique mais de la misère
aussi sociale puisque elles étaient
prostituées dans une maison close
terrible qu'on appelait le genre de
maison qu'on appelait des maisons
d'abattage avec 50 passe par jour donc
ça devait être effroyable comme aux
conditions de vie elle a réussi à s'en
sortir malgré sa maladie parce qu'elle
est elle a été contaminée par la
syphilis
elle a réussi à accéder en se faisant
oublier de sa ville d'origine et en
arrivant à paris à de meilleures maisons
closes et à se faire épouser ce qui
arrive est évidemment très rarement mais
qui était le rêve de beaucoup par un
riche client qui a été sincèrement alors
amoureux d'elle ça je sais pas mais en
tout cas qui s'est sincèrement préoccupé
de son bien-être qui lui passait un peu
seraient ses envies et notamment de
s'initier à l'aviation où elle a été une
pionnière assez incroyable et abala est
devenue une héroïne oui mais lorsque
c'était au moment où de cette photo en
fait son mari va mourir pendant la
première guerre mondiale et elle veut
absolument se s'engager comme pilote de
chasse puisqu'elle est une très bonne
aviatrice et on refuse évidemment parce
qu'elle est une femme et elle va devenir
espionnes et là il donne à devenir très
célèbre après la guerre grâce à ses
mémoires très romancé sur ces son
activité despiau d'eads espionne à
l'horizontale en plus ce qui devait
beaucoup peut exciter tout le monde mais
de tout ça on nous on va tout oublié on
ne se souviendra que de la fermeture des
maisons closes
la fameuse loi marthe richard de 1946
alors chez sais plus quelle est la photo
suivante on va la découvrir ensemble
ah non c'est pas elle mais on va la
regarder quand même parce qu'elle est
formidable 1838 un béguin type alors que
vous nous racontiez parce que c'est vrai
que ce qu'on voit là c'est donc une des
premières photos c'est daguerre qui
invente le daguerréotype on voit le
boulevard du temple et il est
complètement vide et on se dit forcément
ça nous rappelle le confinement
mais andy du centre bourg il y avait un
peu le choléra mais on n'avait pas
confirmé alors expliquez nous pourquoi
cette rue est vide alors c'est ça qui
est vraiment très amusant cette rue
n'est pas vite du tout elle est pleine
de monde
il est huit heures du matin en avril ou
en mai et l épreuve l'an au moins pour
les trottoirs sinon pour l'intérieur de
la rue recouverte de gens que on ne voit
pas qui ont été vraiment transformé en
fantôme par le système de pose du gard
daguerréotype qui nécessité plusieurs
minutes voire jusqu'à 20 minutes de
pause pour pouvoir imprimer l'image tout
ce qui bougeait pas comme les immeubles
les arbres et les panneaux sont demeurés
et un seul homme un seul homme est
demeuré pourquoi parce que cet homme est
resté immobile pendant tout le temps de
la prise les daguerréotypes et cet homme
là que vous pointez du doigt cet homme
là on fait était en train de se faire
polir ses chaussures et grâce à ça il
est rentré dans l'histoire puisque 1838
c'est avant même la date de l'invention
officielle de la photographie qui était
l'année suivante
peut-être d'ailleurs qu'il a eu une
photo d'un homme en 1837 monsieur hu est
le portrait de monsieur hulot
mais ces sujets à caution et ça jamais
été revendiqués comme tels par daguerre
peut-être pour des questions politiques
mais du coup cette cette photo est
vraiment fascinante parce que on a un
homme qui ignore totalement qu'il est
rentré dans l'histoire
et à qui sa coquetterie a fait faire un
imprimé l'histoire au sens propre comme
figuré est la suivante on va la trouver
très moderne également puisque alors
vous avez à de ce côté là à gauche
un couple se promenant en 1932 avec des
masques et à droite 1
un homme dans un dans un tramway
importante à masquer refusant à celui
qui n'en portent pas de monter qu'est ce
qui se passe en 1932 et qu'est ce qui se
passe en 1918 alors en 1918 il ya la
fameuse grippe espagnole fort mal nommée
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas du tout
espagnol
elle était américaine et pourquoi on l'a
appelée grippe espagnole
parce que ce sont des espagnols qui ont
documenté cette grippe qui ont expliqué
le nombre de morts qu'ils avaient dans
leur pays qu'ils étaient bien moindres
que les dommages qui a eu lieu aux états
unis et dans les autres pays européens
sauf que tous les autres pays
occidentaux se sont bien gardés d'en
parler et de communiquer ça trop de
manière trop claires à leurs populations
parce que leur population avait été
tellement éprouvée par 4 ou une année de
conflit du côté des états unis que
c'était plus le moment d'apporter des
nouvelles sinistre et finalement ce sont
des espagnols qui ont eu bon dos parce
que dans la mesure où eux ont été
transparents sur l'information
on a dit que la grippe venait de chez
eux donc à seattle plus précisément là
où on a découvert les prémices de cette
l'expansion de la grippe deux hommes
cherchent à monter dans un tramway on
envoie un qui est masqué qui aura le
droit de monter mais l'autre son
compagnon qui a peut-être oublié son
masque et à qui le contrôleur fait signe
qu' il ne peut pas monter sans masque
pourquoi parce qu'on s'était aperçu
comme aujourd'hui d'ailleurs que le seul
moyen de lutter efficacement contre
contre la grippe était d'empêcher sa
propagation aérienne alors en 1932
c'est également une grippe c'est plus la
grippe espagnole
mais le couple qu'on voit un masque de
manière enfin un masque très élégant
puisque c'est un masque en cuir sont
deux anglais à londres et ils portent
bien leurs l'élégance britannique et la
réputation des groupes britanniques
puisque
là j'ai jamais croisé personne
personnellement à paris depuis un nom
qui est porté un masque en cuir aux
répète que je m'en fasse un pour être là
retard oui sans doute effectivement et
autres autre image assez fascinante
elles datent de 1936 c'est l'image de
droite
cette photo est devenue assez célèbre on
y voit une et en allemagne nazie donc on
y voit énormément de dom pour je ne sais
plus quelle occasion venez nous le dire
faisant le salut nazi
tous sauf un sauf un imperturbable qui
ne s'allume pas et on s'est demandé qui
était cet homme et on a fini par trouver
un et en couleurs il est encore plus
présent qu'il ne l'est sur la photo
originale en noir et blanc
oui je trouve cette photo vraiment
particulièrement touchante
alors comme vous je vais je la
connaissais effectivement mais auguste
landes besser l'homme convoi qui est
tous allés à croiser les bras dans une
foule de gens qui font le salut nazi
faut vraiment se remémorer ce que ça
signifiait même en 1936 donc même quatre
ans 3 4 ans avant le début de la guerre
c'était d'un courage vraiment
sur une maryse il est presque parce que
on risqué sa vie en fait tout simplement
en saluant pas et augustin de mes soeurs
il a un parcours extrêmement touchants
et triste à la fois puisque il avait
voulu l'année précédente se marier avec
la femme qu'il aimait qui était juive et
en vertu des lois de lois de nuremberg
de 1935 qui n'avait pas eu la
possibilité de se marier avec elle
puisque les juifs étaient déchus de leur
nationalité et il était simplement unis
avec elle ce qui déjà était dangereux
pour sa vie puisque l'huile était censé
être un allemand a rien comme disait et
leurs deux petites filles étaient en
danger
coup sur coup il avait été arrêté à la
naissance de la première petite fille
qui ait lieu après la photo puis mais il
s'en est sorti en disant que vraiment il
était désolé et qu' il n'avait pas fait
exprès en somme la deuxième petite fille
c'était beaucoup plus compliqué il avait
même fait de la prison sa femme a été
finalement déportés et tués en 1942 et
lui même a été tué au combat en 1944
j'imagine qu'il n'avait aucune envie de
se battre du côté nazis et pourtant il a
dû être contraint de prendre les armes
j'imagine qu'on l'a menacé de tuer et
j'ignore les circonstances exactes de sa
mort mais ça serait intéressant de
savoir parce que je les imagine
difficilement en train de combattre
réellement du côté naïf et les deux
petites filles elles ont survécu ont
survécu elle lâché martine veut suggérer
également regardant cette photo et en
couleurs on peut effectivement se poser
la question
il ne salue pas il ya deux hommes
derrière qui ont l'air de discuter de
savoir s'il ne faudrait pas le dénoncer
ou pas alors on essaie peut-être
malveillant de penser une chose pareille
mais c'est vrai que quand on regarde
bien la photo on peut se poser la
question effectivement alors sans être
malveillant parce que vraiment il ya un
livre que j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle
seul dans berlin de hand fallada qui est
vraiment un témoignage extraordinaire
sur le vécu d'un allemand pendant la la
le nazisme
on voit bien à quel point la terreur
nazie était retorse dans la mesure où
c'était le simple fait de ne pas
dénoncer qui faisait une peur qui
faisait éprouvé une preures effroyable
parce que ne pas dénoncer était déjà
être coupable ne pas dénoncer était être
autant coupable qu'un homme qui ne
savait pas qui était lui-même considéré
comme un terroriste et qui méritait la
mort donc du coup ne pas dénoncer
quelqu'un qui méritait la mort faisait
plus ou moins mérité la mort donc les
deux hommes derrière ils peuvent
peut-être admiré le courage de landes
mes soeurs ça c'est certain qu'il ya
forcément une part d'eux qu'ils le
pensent mais ils pensent probablement
aussi surtout ce qui va leur arriver eux
directement s'ils ne le dénonce pas et
ça c'est pas malheureusement c'est pas
être malveillant que d'y penser c'est
simplement oui
connaître la réalité du la terreur nazie
plus gai la photo suivante qui nous
montre deux américaine utilisant de la
crème solaire et vient juste d'être
inventé on est en 1935 et c'est fou
comme la la jeune femme dont on voit le
dos et nous semble véritablement elle
ressemble aux jeunes femmes
d'aujourd'hui dans leur attitude louis
blouin est l'atout d'un atout de la star
du second un du second xxème siècle ou
deux ou de 2020 mais ça c'est évident
qu'on a l'impression de voir une fille
d'aujourd'hui
alors après peut-être que les les
maillots de bain sont un petit peu datés
mais un mais c'est vrai que la couleur
leur rend justice est en revanche la
photo suivante là on ne pourrait plus à
prendre aujourd'hui c'est absolument
impossible a été prise en 1938 et on y
voit des gens pique-niquant au sommet de
la pyramide de khéops
donc ça c'est devenu impossible
c'est interdit ah ça c'est
rigoureusement interdit effectivement si
on essaie de faire la même chose c'est
on se fait mettre en prison où il a une
forte amende
mais c'est vrai que c'est amusant de
voir ce coup ça c'est pendant ces
couples ces cinq personnes trois hommes
et deux pendant trois 3 femmes et deux
hommes qui sont presque énervant dans
l'eure dans leur attitude tellement
tellement beau tellement aristocrate
peut-être de vacances se faisant servir
le thé tranquillement en eau de khéops
et j'ai trouvé cette photo vraiment
génial sur les premiers touristes qui a
joué cette condition qu'ils sont
vraiment très éloigné du tourisme et du
vin de masse qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
des américaine en 1941
on va les voir maintenant là aussi mais
tout ça c'est très drôle parce que je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué beaucoup
de photos que vous montrez vont à
l'encontre de tout ce qu'on imagine qui
était la condition de la femme
autrefois on a l'impression d'être plus
en plus l'impression que la condition de
la femme s'était quasiment être une
esclave arrimé à sa cuisine
et quand on voit les photos s'aperçoit
que ce n'était pas le cas de tout le
monde quand même hein et notamment pas
de ces jeunes femmes là non
effectivement évidemment c'est un
travers de la société actuelle de
caricaturer le passé la ccc femme là qui
caricaturent les hommes elles ont décidé
de se moquer ce sont soit des épouses
soit des soeurs soit des des filles qui
sont agacés par une attitude à l'époque
en 1941 il y avait une habitude aux
états unis qui était de faire des stocks
1 ait des
des soirées à schumer entre hommes et
donc du coup elle a les signes de
prendre des hommes au pied de la lettre
et de faire une et dix smoker knight et
là c'était assez a fait les choux gras
de la presse le lendemain parce qu'elles
ont tout fait pour attirer l'attention
de des hommes en faisant venir une strip
teaseuse un combat de boxe
évidemment en clamant tellement qu'on a
retrouvé enfin on a essayé de calculer
le nombre de paquets qui avaient été
consommées c'était plus ou moins deux
paquets par femme part pour ce soir là
donc deux paquets par don de deux
cartouches de cigarettes sans compter
les pipes et c'est donc c'est très
amusant et évidemment qu'on voit le le
libre la libre pensée et la liberté de
ces femmes de narguer les hommes et une
dernière chicago la même année 1941
on croirait une pochette de disque elle
est magnifique
une pochette de disque presque
d'aujourd'hui l'un dans la composition
on sait qui est qui et celui qui est au
milieu un il a 14 ans
on a réussi à le retrouver comme
beaucoup de jours d'ailleurs dans les
photos de votre livre il ya beaucoup de
gens dont vous donner les noms vous
savez qui c'est oui oui en revanche ça
s'est un peu plus frustrant parce qu'on
connaît pas l'identité des quatre autres
jeunes garçons mais je trouve que leur
look est génial alors dans mon livre
j'ai cherché à faire 20 chapitres pour
montrer un peu les les 20 h aux les plus
représentatives de de ce siècle entre
1838 et 1945
et là je les ai mis dans la mode parce
que je trouve que ils ont une dégaine
incroyable une élégance et puis sont
tous avec des borsalinos sauf celui du
milieu celui qu'on connaît ils ont tous
avec des bords salino alors qu'ils ont
au maximum cas à 14 ans comme celui du
centre est vraiment je trouve que leur
élégance est à nulle autre nul autre
pareil avec leur petite pochette là si
on regarde le jeune homme a à gauche
envers là il a une pochette qui dépasse
c'est vraiment c est du dernier chic et
je trouve ça génial et vous avez raison
ça pourrait bien faire à la pochette de
l'album d'un album merci hugo et mines
ils vivent est aux couleurs 1838 1945 un
livre pour remonter le temps c'est signé
rodrigo et mines ça vient de paraître
aux éditions du chêne on en a même pas
regardé le cas où une cinquième my hand
a énormément énormément de photos dans
ce livre merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]